So we already know that ILP is not equal to
IPC on any real processor, actually it can be but it's
not necessarily, so, and that is because ILP is really
the IPC on a perfect processor that does perfect branch prediction.
And only has to follow data dependencies, so now let's
look at an example of a program and a real processor
and see basically how do we determine ILP, and and how
do we determine the IPC. So this is our program, and
now let's look at what the processor looks
like. So our processor is two issue, meaning it
can handle two instructions per cycle. Out of
order super scalar, which means that it doesn't need
to execute instructions exactly in program order. And
let's say that it only has one multiplication unit,
and two units that can do what add, subtract,
x, or et cetera. For our ILP, we can
just ignore all of this, because the ILP, again, is
just the property of a program. So we have to
just obey dependencies. There is a data dependence here, and
that's only really the only dependence that we have. So as
far as ILP is concerned, we can do this in
two cycles. This, this, this, and this would be done in
the first cycle, and then this would be done in
the second cycle because it, it depends on the instruction that
is done in the first cycle. So we have five instructions, over two cycles,
gives us 2.5. In contrast, the IPC for this processor
needs to consider all the limitations of this processor. So we have this
instruction can be done in the first cycle. This
one cannot because of a dependence, so therefor the
IPC we still have to obey all the dependencies,
plus we have to also worry about the other limitations
of the processor. This is an out-of-order processor, so
we are not doing this. But we can still
look further, because we can do instructions out of
order. The XOR can be done because we have two
add subtracted et cetera units so we can do
this in the first cycle two. This instruction can be
done in the first cycle, because we can use
the multiplier. For example, this instruction here cannot be done
in the first cycle unlike when we computed the
ILP. It can not be done, because we only have
two add, subtract, x, or et cetera units, and
we have already consumed both of them in the first
cycle for the add and the XOR. So in
the second cycle now, we can do this and this.
So it turns out that I, our IBC is still
five instructions over two cycles equals 2.5. But it doesn't
have to be that way. For example, if this
processor only had one, I would subtract extra units.
We would now have the IPC off. In the
first cycle we can do this. We cannot do this
because of a dependence. We cannot do this because
are already using our one unit that we have for
an [UNKNOWN], et cetera. We can do the multiply,
and we can't do this add either. In the second
cycle, we can do this. We can not do
any of these other two because, again, we are
using our add subtract XOR. This will be our
third cycle, and this will be our fourth cycle.
So, now we have five instructions over four cycles.
And that's equal to 1.25. So this IPC is
half of this IPC, and half of this ILP. So what we can say is that the IPC
has to be less than or equal to the
ILP. The ILPs for a perfect PROCESSOR. A real prosser
will have some limitations that will maybe allow it to
achieve the same IPC as the ILP available in the
application. But sometimes it will not. So what we can
say is that the ILP is always greater than or
equal to the IPC on any real PROCESSOR. And again,
we don't really need to know what the prosser is
to compute the ILP, but we do need to know what
the prosser looks like when we're computing it's IPC. And we have
seen that IPC can be equal to the ILP, or it can
be lower than that, but it can not be larger than that.